hi i'm santos lo i'm a food stylist
food stylists are the ones that
interpret a recipe into an image form
for tv print or social media whenever
you see an image of food odds are a food
stylist had a hand in it i've been food
styling for 16 years 10 of those years i
worked at food network six years i've
been doing commercials cookbooks
magazines and a lot of youtube shows
[Music]
let me style the pb j for you
you've seen one a million times before
three ingredients peanut butter jelly
and bread
when i think about a pv j i think about
all the different components and the
possibilities i think about bread and
how it can bend it can tear it can
crumble
i think about jelly how it can drip and
how if i spread it thin enough it can be
translucent and i think about peanut
butter and how thick it is how gloppy it
is and how it can be a glue if i want it
to be okay let's start with the bread
for me this is the right shape for this
peanut butter and jelly sandwich so
let's spread some peanut butter on it
now
so i'm just concerned about what it's
going to look like on the edges because
that's what you're gonna see and i'm not
gonna spread it just flat i wanna try
and create layers because layers in this
case i will say it's creamy and i feel
like it needs a little bit of texture so
let's say this peanut butter is chunky
peanut butter i want to chop the peanuts
myself because i can control the shape
and i can control the placement and i
don't want to place them evenly i want
it to be random i want it to look
natural
all right now it's time for the jelly i
want to put the jelly
where the peanut butter isn't dripping
over the bread and again i want this to
look natural and so i need to look at
this from different angles i'll look at
it from the top and then i'll look at it
from the side
it'd be nice to get a drip here
and also it'd be nice to get a little
bit of drip on the board
you know it would look good too if i put
a piece of peanut on the board as if it
just fell over
okay so let me prepare the top slice
spread a little bit of jelly on there so
it doesn't look so clean and i'm just
gently going to press it onto the rest
of the sandwich okay being really
careful not to mess up all of the things
that you just built up
and so what i'm showing you here is a
peanut butter and jelly sandwich where
the three components are being shown off
in the best way possible the peanut
butter looks creamy and chunky and then
you have the jelly that's got the
perfect consistency right it's not too
loose but it's runny enough and then you
have the bread right with just a little
bit of crumbs around the edges a really
nice golden color
and when you're flipping through a
cookbook
this will get your attention this is
what you'll want to sink your teeth into
one way i can create a pb j for you is
by showing you less
let's talk about how little i can show
you but still say peanut butter and
jelly sandwich
the bread
do i need to show you a whole slice no
you've seen that a million times let me
just show you a part of the slice
what about the peanut butter and the
jelly do i need to show you the amount
that you would put
in a typical peanut butter and jelly
sandwich i don't think so what if i just
show you a couple drops here and there
and what if i frame it in a way that
describes the shape without showing you
the whole thing
this is an example of less is more where
i'm showing you a little bit and your
mind is filling in the rest that is a
more exciting image to look at than one
that is finished for you
okay now let me show you even less
i'm just simply gonna put some peanut
butter on a knife
put a jar of jelly next to it and then a
piece of bread
you have the three components but
look how little i've shown you and if
you were flipping through a cookbook and
you stopped at this page you would still
know
that it's a peanut butter and jelly
sandwich
[Music]
okay let's have some fun let's set the
scene for a peanut butter and jelly
sandwich okay we have the plate we have
the knife
and we have a glass of milk
looks good
nah this is boring let's take away the
knife and what if i draw the knife
in jelly
still looks like a knife all right now
let me take the glass away let me draw
that in jelly
okay now let's take the plate away
and let's just do a big circle in jelly
now if i tell you that's a plate it's a
plate
and actually let's put milk in it let's
see if we can put milk into this thing
and of course we have the sandwich on
the plate
this is saying the same thing but it's
different it's unique
it's colorful
it's original
and it catches your eye think about when
you're flipping
through pages in a cookbook you'll want
to stop at this you probably will
because you think
what is this that's special guys
every food stylist will interpret a
peanut butter and jelly sandwich
different and the next time you're
looking at a cookbook find the story
there's always the unique perspective
that every food stylist brings to the
table
i love playing with my food food is like
paint it's like clay i strip it away i
take it apart and then i rebuild it it's
all for me about adding and subtracting
about
finding its boundaries finding its
breaking point knowing what it can do
and what it can
i want the food to speak to me
that is the job of a food stylist
[Music]
you